guten tag ich bin khadri
ich bin immer nur ich mache mit emanuel
ein video
ich mache mit karin video pass aufpassen
was ist denn los was mir los das haben
wir hier nicht mit hammer hier nicht das
weiß ich nicht weiß ich nicht ich bin
ich bin's das finde ich gut
wie gut ich hätte gern einen kaffee mit
milch im kaffee mit milch
[Musik]
meinst du mich
ich habe mir heute ausnahmsweise mal ein
ticket gekauft
ich hab mal ausnahmsweise mal ein
fahrschein gekauft
mach mal deine augen auf die oft ich
habe mir das lange genug angehört ich
habe mir lange noch angehört dafür sonst
noch was sein darf sonst so weit sein
ich hab dich gestern am alex gesehen
ich hab da gestern am alex sie sehen da
habe ich mich gefreut
daher freut hast du auch bock auf kino
the box kino nee ich war gestern schon
im kino weg war ja schon im kino gewesen
ich habe mich in letzter zeit viel mit
quantenmechanik beschäftigt ich hab mal
in letzter zeit viel mit quantenmechanik
beschäftigt 11 uhr ist mir auf jeden
fall zu spät
elvis mir auf jeden fall zu spät
das war das leckerste bier was sich seit
der mittagspause getrunken habe dittwar
leckerste bier war die zeit der
mittagspause getrunken habe schönen tag
nach schönen tag noch
das waren etwa 20 sätze sonst die sätze
von berlinerisch dialekt zum berliner
rischen dialekt in diesen mit emanuel
vom berühmten blockierer daily themen
und kari combino so gerühmten instagram
channel easy german jetzt könnt ihr
nachbar emanuel vorbeigucken und dort
mehr deutsch lernen den link zu seinem
blog findet ihr unten in unserer infobox
oder ihr klickt euch paris ganzen
anderen videos an die hier überall das
bild voll kleistern klickt einfach
irgendwo drauf wir nicht vergessen like
-button drücken subscriber wester
nächsten woche dann gibt's vielleicht
noch mehr
oder vielleicht nicht